[Musik]
was glauben sie ist die stärkste
triebkraft des menschen leid
[Musik]
9 angst flughafen leipzig 29 zehnter
2015 die damalige fdp chef in frauke
petry erwartet einen wichtigen gast
herr conle dunkle hornbrille lederjacke
kurzer bad wenig haar treffpunkt
flughafen ausgang werden circa 11 15
london grußwort see in diesem hotel soll
henning konnte der besucher aus der
schweiz
afg chefin petra ein angebot gemacht
haben als ich herrn konnte das erste mal
traf sagte mir seine person nichts
mein eindruck war dass henning konnte
die afg unterstützen wollte mein
eindruck war aber auch dass er letztlich
dabei nicht persönlich in erscheinung
treten wollte der milliardär henning
konnte lebt in zürich und london
es gibt keine fotos von ihm frauke petry
macht erstmals öffentlich dass
immobilienunternehmer conle aktiv die
nähe zur afg führung suchte mit einem
illegalen spenden angebot
damals hatte ich das gefühl dass mir bei
dem vorgehen
oder wenn über die offensichtlichen
ideen konnte es nicht wohl war aber für
mich war immer klar und das habe ich
auch denke ich deutlich gemacht
legale unterstützung ist in ordnung denn
das parteienrecht bietet dafür genug
möglichkeiten illegale kamen überhaupt
gar nicht in frage
für andere schon
die afg spitzenpolitikerin alice seidel
erhielt im sommer 2017 132.000 euro
gestückelte spenden verschleiert durch
strohleute die bundestagsverwaltung
ermittelte und enthüllte mit hilfe von
schweizer bank unterlagen den waren
beide spender aus diesen unterlagen geht
nunmehr als tatsächliche spender herr
henning konnte hervor
der fall der weide spende ist einer bei
dem genau das passiert ist wasser kohle
hier offensichtlich angekündigt hat er
hat nämlich versucht anonym an die afg
zu spenden das war ganz klar illegal was
weil und aber auch zahlreiche andere
ganz offensichtlich nach recherchen dann
nach meinen treffen mit herrn koller
getan haben
das war eben genau die bereitschaft
illegale spenden anzunehmen und sich
dadurch persönlich einen vorteil
verschaffen
mehrfach sagt petry habe sie sich mit
milliardär conle getroffen
er fragte mich recht bald was meiner
ansicht nach die wichtigste triebkraft
des menschen sei ich nehme an dass es
neid und gier sind eher sagte angst sei
die stärkste triebkraft des menschen und
mir war das unangenehm angst das ist das
zentrale thema mehrere wahlkampagnen ab
dem frühjahr 2016 tauchen in
landtagswahlkämpfen plakate und
zeitungen auf die für die afg werben
aber nicht von der partei stammen
sondern von einem verein die afg
behauptet sie habe nichts mit dem verein
recht und freiheit zu tun
bei diesem verein trat die von konnte
finanziell unterstützte alice seidel als
rednerin auf es ist mir eine große ehre
hier heute zu ihnen sprechen zu dürfen
steckt henning conle hinter dem verein
der die partei mit zeitungen und
großplakaten im wert von mehreren
millionen euro unterstützte der verein
gibt dazu keine auskunft
[Musik]
fest steht auch jörg neuten bekam 2016
unterstützung für seinen wahlkampf in
baden württemberg plakate und
zeitungsanzeigen angeblich finanziert
von einer schweizer werbefirma
auf nachfrage der bundestagsverwaltung
legte die afg später listen mit den
namen angeblicher spender vor
doch die erwiesen sich als strohleute
einer von ihnen ein mitarbeiter einer
konnte firma sein name philipp m
die bundestagsverwaltung verhängte gegen
leuten eine strafe 270.000 euro vor
gericht klagte die afg dagegen erfolglos
finanzierte milliardär konnte auch die
werbekampagne für meuten ich kann mich
erinnern dass irgendwann im herbst er in
großer sorge darüber war ob er
tatsächlich als spitzenkandidat in baden
württemberg würde antreten können weil
ihm dazu die nötigen finanzen fehlen im
november 2015 beklagten sich bei petri
mehrfach über fehlendes geld für seinen
landtagswahlkampf
wenn ich also kein geld für den
wahlkampf haben werde werde ich auch
keinen aussichtslosen kampf führen
ich kann ohne eigenes eingebrachtes geld
im wahlkampf nicht gewinnen
petri sagt sie und leuten hätten sich
danach im dezember 2015 mit henning
konnte in der schweiz verabredet montag
zürich klappt bei mir
liebe grüße jörg ich habe herrn konnte
zusammen mit jungen leuten im dezember
2015 in zürich getroffen
nach aussage von petri in einer von
kunduz willen bei zürich
küssnacht siebter 12 2015
an diesem tag soll henning konnte das
damalige afg spitzenduo frauke petry und
jörg leuten in seiner villa getroffen
haben
so erzählt es petri leuten hatte über
geldsorgen im wahlkampf geklagt nun habe
er geld dafür gehabt berichtet ein
früherer vertrauter mitte dezember 2015
gab es zu meiner verwunderung war eine
kleine änderungen weil die leute dann im
am rande einer wahlkampfveranstaltung zu
mir kam und mir einen scheck in die hand
drückte der arm eines meiner erinnerung
nach auch auf seinen namen wie mit 5000
euro
diese summe sollte ich dann ein zahlen
auf dem kreisverbands konto für seinen
wahlkampf
auf nachfrage ob er geld von konten
erhalten habe verweigert der afg chef
die auskunft wie auch schon vor zwei
jahren im zdf hatte immobilien
milliardär henning kohle sie finanziell
unterstützt ich werde in dieser spenden
sache gegenüber medienvertretern auch
ihnen gegenüber keine auskunft mehr
geben
wir geben vollinhaltlich auskunft
gegenüber der bundestagsverwaltung
mehrfach hat die bundestagsverwaltung
einzelne illegale spenden an afd
politiker aufgedeckt doch die affäre
könnte viel größer sein
im moment mehren sich eben die indizien
dass es möglicherweise keine
verschiedenen spendenaffären sondern
eine einzige große spendenaffäre ist
hinter der herr kunde steckt aber ein
erster verdacht liegt da auf alle fälle
auf der hand dass sich das
möglicherweise auch noch ausweitet und
möglicherweise dann auch noch weitere
strafzahlungen auf die afg zu kommen
frauke petry verließ die afg 2017
direkt nach der bundestagswahl sie hat
lange geschwiegen jetzt erhebt sie
schwere vorwürfe gegen ihre früheren
parteifreunde das für mich ein tabu war
illegale spenden anzunehmen war für
andere offenbar kein solches wie wir
heute wissen haben jörg motten und alice
weil spenden angenommen und haben sich
dadurch nicht nur persönlich ablesbar
gemacht um persönlich innerhalb der
partei ihren machtkampf führen zu können
sondern sie haben dadurch auch die
gesamte partei ablesbar gemacht henning
konnte der heimliche afd unterstützer
reagierte nicht auf anfragen von
frontal21 und korrektiv
[Musik]